This is Andy McDonald and I am an assistant scoutmaster with Troop 631 in Oviedo, Florida,
And this edition of the Scoutmaster podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
And now to you, Scoutmaster.
Very recently this report came across my desk.
It is from a bunch of very dedicated scouters studying different things about camping and
scouting at the Large Baden Collider in Zern, Switzerland,
And they have just completed a series of experiments that have determined there is
actually what is called a tootin common effect.
That's right, a tootin common effect,
And that is that the urgency with which a person sleeping in a mummy sleeping bag
must exit the mummy sleeping bag is in inverse proportion to the air temperature
and the degree of difficulty in operating the bag's zipper.
It's official,
It's science.
What can I say?
Hey, this is podcast number 310..
Hey,
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast.
This is Clark Greene
Speaking as we always do to the mailbag. we heard from an anonymous commenter about our
last couple of podcasts.
This will be number 3, where we're talking about parents,
But for the past couple of podcasts we've talked about different things with parents
And they had this to say: the podcasts are all gems,
But at this point in the life of our troop, this particular issue is in the top two.
Once again, you must be listening in on troop and committee meetings
And overhearing parent conversations.
Well, I am not personally, but I do have agents everywhere.
You've just armed our Scouts and adult leaders with what they need to educate some of our
parents.
How do I educate the other side of the equation,
An overbearing troop committee?
Maybe we need a committee chair CG podcast to help our committee chair.
The Scouts haven't nailed the parents,
Not so much.
Well, my anonymous friend, this is pretty much par for the course.
This is not something that will ever, ever go away.
It's always been there. since the first troop opened the doors to its meeting room a hundred
and some years ago,
This issue has always been there.
We're always going to be working with the expectations of adults versus the expectations
of the Scouting program.
We have to spend time learning to understand what the Scouting program is, because it's
very different from most of the other things that we have worked with with young people.
So, yeah, it's probably on everybody's top lists of dealing with these issues with parents
and with other volunteers.
So don't feel so all alone,
And eventually it gets better as you go along. if you just, if you just stick with it.
This comment from troop 206 via Twitter:
Just listen to podcast 309..
Thanks.
Some parents think that we quote unquote- should be Eagle Scouting.
Your opinion,
Is it a journey or a destination?
Well, that's a pretty softball question,
And it's another issue that comes with the territory, and one that gets better as we
better understand what Scouting is all about.
Naturally, it's about the journey.
The destination-
Oh, it's a great destination.
You become an Eagle Scout.
That's great.
Becoming an Eagle Scout is simply an indicator that you've successfully
completed the requirements and hopefully, all those Scouts that become Eagle
Scouts have also experienced all the wonderful things along the way.
We encourage your Scouts to pay attention to what's happening now today in front of
them.
Yeah, you should have some goals, but not so that you miss being able to see
what's going on along the way, right.
Every week, we have a couple of live chat sessions
Now. these are usually conducted on Tuesday mornings and Wednesday mornings.
You will see an announcement in our Twitter feed and in our Facebook feed
that we will be live at scoutmastercgcom.
Come and join the many, many people who join us during our live chat sessions
Have a lot of folks who show up just about every week and we call those our
frequent fliers. but in addition to those, this past week we also heard from
Scott Vessel, who is a unit and district chaplain in Central Texas, Adam Albert,
who is in Napoleon, Michigan, where he's an assistant scoutmaster with
Troop 472, and Jill, who is a scoutmaster of Troop 3 in Sharon, Pennsylvania,
and Ken DePascaretta, who's the scoutmaster for Troop 74 in Chelmsford, Massachusetts.
So it was great to hear from everybody on the chat this week.
Like I said, keep an eye on the Facebook feed and the Twitter feed and
come and join us.
It's great fun.
If you're a longtime reader and listener, you will be familiar with the stuff
Scouters Say T-Shirt- something we did- oh my gosh, I guess it's about three years ago
And I was trying out one way of, you know, making T-shirts and offering them to you.
I've found a pretty good solution. I think
I am able to offer you this Stuff Scouters Say T-Shirt at Amazon at what I hope
is a reasonable price.
Look in the podcast notes for podcast 310 and you'll see a link if you're
interested in taking a look at that shirt.
And I should tell you if you're not familiar with it. this T-shirt has on it
about 200 phrases that scouts say a lot.
Okay,
And just to give you an example, I've got a shirt right here
Giving an example. what five? second rule:
Where's the coffee?
Do you think that's clean?
That's not clean yet.
Do you think that is dry?
That is not dry yet.
What were you thinking?
Were you thinking at all?
Who has the Advil?
No, we're not there yet.
No, we are still not there.
It's just over this hill.
So you get the idea.
About 200 phrases like that.
So when you wear the shirt and you're working with your scouts,
you can save your voice by pointing to the phrase on the shirt,
And it's just kind of a lot of fun too.
So once again in the podcast notes link to wear the shirts
available on Amazon.
I hope you enjoy it.
Hey, if you are a regular reader and listener and the resources
we create help you, here's two ways you can return the favor.
You can support the podcast by making a one-time payment
and becoming a ScoutmasterCGcom backer.
Or you can make a subscription payment through Patreon
by pledging $5 or more each month.
Now there are special premiums available to anyone
who becomes a patron or a backer.
And to become a backer, just go to ScoutmasterCGcom,
Click the support link at the top of the page
and you'll find a number of options
that will make you a backer.
To become a patron, go to my Patreon page-
And there's a link right at the top of the page
at ScoutmasterCGcom too, for Patreon.
Or you can go directly to wwwpatreon- p-a-t-r-e-o-ncom,
backslash ScoutmasterCG.
And I want to take a moment to personally thank Malcolm
Bliss, who became a patron since last week's podcast.
So do me a favor, take the time this week,
look into becoming a backer or a patron,
And I'll make sure to thank you personally
during next week's podcast.
In this podcast, our third installment talking
about parents and scouting, and that
is going to take up the remainder of the podcast.
So let's get started, shall we?
One of the things that often comes up
when we're talking about parents and scouting
is their role in the advancement process.
A lot of times parents- especially if younger scouts-
will be concerned when other scouts seem
to bypass their son in advancement,
And they ask a lot of questions about this,
because if they were involved in cub scouts,
advancement is done more or less by the entire den,
And so they've had several years of that
and they come to scouting and they find out:
oh, that's not exactly the way that it happens
in a scout troop,
And that can be a little confusing.
And even if they do understand that the scout troop
is a little different, moms and dads
can get a little overheated when it comes
to their son's advancement.
Sometimes they can be gently dissuaded from this
by a quiet reminder of who does what and why,
and sometimes not.
So here's my golden rule for working with parents
and scouting.
An important thing to know is that a scout
should never be made to suffer for anything
beyond their control,
And the attitudes and actions of their parents
are usually going to be beyond the scout's control, correct?
You don't choose your parents
And you don't get to tell your parents how to act.
So that bear is repeating.
A scout should never be made to suffer
for things beyond their control,
And the attitudes and actions of their parents
are definitely beyond their control.
We don't want scouts to feel put out
or to suffer for the attitudes and actions
of their parents,
And that's why I'm going to encourage you:
when it comes to advancement,
don't put on the brakes and don't press the gas pedal.
The scouts themselves will figure out
how much they're interested in advancing,
how fast they want to go.
Parents don't always understand that
and parents may get a little overheated.
But, like I said,
resist the urge to put on the brake,
resist the urge to push the gas pedal.
let scouts individually figure out
how fast they want to advance
and accept the fact that in some cases
parents are going to be pushing them,
and don't make your scouts suffer
because their parents are being pushy.
When we're talking to parents about advancement,
here are a couple of key thoughts for them.
Scouts can't fall behind or be bypassed
when it comes to advancement.
Scouts do things when they want,
when they're ready to do them.
Some do them faster than others,
some do them slower,
Sometimes they don't do them at all,
And any of one of those three ways
of being a scout is perfectly acceptable to me.
During the years that they're in a scout troop,
some of their fellow scouts
are going to advance faster,
but that is not necessarily a reflection
on an individual scout's intelligence,
interest or engagement.
So that's one thing I like to share with parents.
that points out that when we're talking
about scouts in a scout troop,
they can advance at any speed they wish
and they can choose to advance not at all.
Now, usually scouts think that's a great idea,
until a scout starts advancing too fast
and they want to put the brakes on.
So there's only one way to earn a rank,
There's only one way to earn a merit badge
or any other advancement in scouting,
and that is to complete the requirements for them.
If we agree that there is no such thing
as completing the requirements too slowly,
we also must agree that there is no such thing
as completing the requirements too quickly.
So have plenty of room in your mind
and in your heart and in your program
for scouts who want to advance quickly
and scouts who want to advance slowly,
And those will not always be the same scouts,
You know. one year slow, next year fast,
next year slow. it's the scout's decision.
The other really important thing to understand-
and a lot of parents don't-
is that the fulfillment of merit badge requirements
is a matter for merit badge counselors
and scouts to decide
and not scoutmasters or assistant scoutmasters,
except if they also are in the role
of a merit badge counselor.
What you think about a given requirement
in a given situation for a given merit badge
with a given scout is really doesn't amount to anything,
because the counselor is going to make that decision.
And in addition to those two thoughts
I would also get out the Guide to Advancement 2015
and make sure parents have all read
a reasonably brief but a very important statement
in the Guide to Advancement called personal growth
is the prime consideration for advancement.
And that is in the Guide to Advancement.
it's all numbers right,
So get your pencils ready.
It's 2.0.0.3,. personal growth is prime consideration.
It's brief, but it's very to the point
and it's important thing for parents to know.
And it's brief enough for me to read it in its entirety.
Quote: scouting skills-
what a young person learns to do- are important,
but not as important as the growth achieved
through participating in a unit program.
The concern is for total, well-rounded development.
Age-appropriate, surmountable hurdles
are placed before members and as they face them,
they learn about themselves and gain confidence.
Success is achieved when we fulfill
the BSA mission statement
and when we accomplish the aims of scouting,
Those being character development,
citizenship training and mental and physical fitness.
We know we are on the right track
when we see youth accepting responsibility,
demonstrating self-reliance
and caring for themselves and others,
When they learn to weave scouting ideals into their lives
and when we can see they will be positive contributors
to our American society.
Though certainly goal-oriented
advancement is not a competition.
Rather it is a joint effort involving the leaders,
the members, other volunteers-
such as merit badge counselors
or venturing consultants- and the family.
Though much is done individually at their own pace,
youth often work together in groups
to focus on achievements and electives
at Cub Scout, then meetings, for example,
or participate in a Boy Scout camp out or Sea Scout cruise.
As they do this, we must recognize
each young person's unique combination
of strengths and weaknesses.
As watchful leaders, either adult or youth,
we lend assistance as called for
and encourage members to help each other
according to their abilities. unquote.
So parents should see and read and understand
that section of the guide to advancement.
They wanna help and that's good.
but they do get anxious and that's difficult,
but that's also very common.
Most scouts are going to go through
a period of inactivity. advancement-wise
It's no big deal,
but parents don't always know that.
It's difficult to redirect their efforts sometimes.
but most scouts are going to survive
and thrive in spite of their parents.
And I've had a lot of scouts
who just aren't interested in advancement at all,
Sometimes for a year, sometimes more,
and they go on to become Eagle Scouts
because when they get it in their minds
that it's something they wanna do.
you really can't stop them,
And I've worked with many, many parents
who I would consider to be overly involved
in their son's scouting experience
And they usually back off and they calm down a little bit
if I can talk to them about the nature of scout advancement.
but sometimes I don't get anywhere, and that's fine
because we're charged to work with our scouts
as they come to us.
We can't change what happens at home.
Remember my little golden rule:
scouts don't get to choose their parents,
so we don't make them suffer for what their parents do.
So let's change our tune here for a moment,
because before I conclude this three-part series
on parents and scouting,
I wanted to make some comments about what it's like
to be a parent and a scouter at the same time,
because characteristics that make a good parent
are very similar to those that make a good scouter.
But we're not going to impose the same expectations
or authority we have for our own children on our scouts.
As adult volunteers in scouting
we have to be sure that we divide our roles
as parent and a scouter
and that we make sure that we understand those two roles
and we do our best not to let them mix together.
Parents are likely to be more demanding
and more critical and more emotional
when they deal with their own children.
Separating the expectations that you have for your child
as your child being their parent
and separating the expectations that you have
for your child as a scout is a little tricky.
You're going to do and say things as a scouter
that will make your child proud
and you'll probably say and do some things
that make them cringe
and they will no doubt return the favor for you.
And somewhere along the way,
occupying both of those roles
is going to cause some tension.
Let's remember your child's reasons for being a scout
are different from your reasons for being a scouter.
Now, sure, you want to spend time with your child
but, as we'd expect, they're probably more interested
in spending time with their friends
when they're with scouts.
We also need to understand that parents and children
have inside information about each other.
They know what goes on at home and at school and at work.
They know each other's history and strengths and weaknesses,
and inside information is going to skew your judgment
as a scouter, because you know things about your child
that nobody else knows,
and it's going to skew your child's objectivity
when it comes to your role as a scouter
because they know things about you
that nobody else knows.
And, if you haven't figured it out already,
every parent has a blind spot,
and sometimes several, when it comes to their own children.
So having a trusted fellow scout
or help you watch for blind spots
and lend some objectivity to this complex pair of relationships
that you have with your child
can make things a lot easier for you and for your child.
Of course, you will return the favor
and watch for their blind spots with their children,
who are involved with scouts too.
Now if you are a parent and a scouter
and you have a child in your unit,
I'd urge you not to switch
between the roles of scouter and parent all that often.
Don't treat a scout as your child one moment
and a scout the next.
Have a consistent approach
that you and your child agree to ahead of time.
Some things I see when young scouts and new scouters
go on their first couple of camping trips
are good illustration of opportunities
to keep the two relationships separate.
So let's say, your child wanders over
and asks for something during a camping trip.
Maybe they forgot to pack something.
The temptation is, of course, to switch into the parent role
and run off and make sure they get whatever they forgot,
But if a scout approached a scouter with the same request,
would we do that?
We'd probably end up telling them
that scouts are expected to bring their own gear
and ask them why they would expect us to have one for them.
And this happens too with food.
The child doesn't like the food
His patrol is preparing. he comes and he finds his parent
and tells them, and usually the parent
shares some food with them.
So the idea is that if you're a parent
and that happens to you,
you have to ask yourself: what would a scouter do?
What would you tell somebody who wasn't your child?
Oh no,
This is what you brought for food.
so that's what you're gonna have.
And, like I said, those problems
are probably gonna come up.
but it would be a good idea. if you're really smart,
you discuss them with your child ahead of time
and you explain that they need to accept
the same responsibility for preparing
and packing for the trip
and for their behavior on the trip
as any other scout would,
Even though you're gonna be there.
you're volunteering to help all the scouts there
and it's really not fair for them
to depend upon you as a parent in that situation.
Now, all. that being said,
you also may wanna arrange for some specific time
within a scouting activity
where you switch from scouter to parent
and you get to be your child's parent for a little while.
Maybe this is a few minutes before bedtime
or just after a meal,
but you can both walk away from the group for a moment,
address any concerns,
share your thoughts with one another as parent and child,
and then go back to your scout and scouter roles.
What we do as parents affects only our children.
What we do as scouters affects other people's children.
If we understand the difference
and prepare our children and ourselves
to observe the boundaries between those two roles
of being a parent and a scouter,
it's very likely we're gonna enjoy scouting together
and better help, all of our scouts at the same time.
["Skouts at the Same Time"].
Well, thanks so much for listening
to this 310th edition of the Scoutmaster Podcast.
Now here's how to keep in touch.
Read the blog at scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there, you can subscribe
to receive updates to the blog by email.
You can also follow the wonders of scoutmastercgcom
in the vast panorama of social media.
You can join the nearly 13,000 folks
who follow us on Facebook,
the 1,500 or so folks who tweet together with us
on Twitter, the 2,500 prolific pinners
who, along with us, pin pultitudinous pictures on Pinterest.
You can watch us at ScoutmasterCG on YouTube.
but listen, if you can't face Facebook
and Twitter makes you better.
and if you've no interest in Pinterest,
if you don't hit the U in YouTube,
well, that's okay. Bunky, just zoom into the late 90s
and fire off a good old-fashioned email.
I'm available at clark at scoutmastercgcom.
C-L-A-R-K-E
at scoutmastercgcom.
Now, if all else fails,
you can write your messages on a piece of paper,
seal it in a bottle and bury it in any campfire circle.
I'll be sure to get it.
I have agents everywhere, I assure you.
Now, by this time, it must be abundantly clear
that the Scoutmaster blog
and the Scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications
of any scouting organization,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored
by any scouting organization.
Nope, it's just me with a microphone
trying to lend a hand to Scoutleaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
And speaking of fun, here, he is our founder,
Sir Robert Bidden Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping,
Why? thank you, sir,
Until next time, everyone.